bref, plus tendu on commence à appeler le
numéro un
nous avons le numéro 2 3 4 5 6 heures aujourd'hui
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une urgence
voyons tout maintenant comme ça
nous avons
prédit était derrière
Non
c'est l'histoire de la GS Excelsior
ce qu'on appelle le plus d'équipe
perdant de l'Italie, une équipe qui ne le fait pas
ne gagne jamais sur un terrain mais gagne
J'ai dit ne me demande pas de faire semblant
de l'exterieur
manger un discours, c'est aller faire le
jeu à perdre mais ça ne me dérange pas
le fait de perdre me pèse bien tu perds
le match parce que si j'encaisse 21 buts par
la montagne, comme cela s'est produit l'année dernière, est
c'est vrai qu'il a fait 21 mixés parce que
nous aurions même pu en faire 30 mais si je
Je prends 21 buts, au moins 18 je pourrais
éviter parce qu'il n'y avait aucun désir parce que
nous n'avons pas couru parce que nous faisons les choses habituelles
des erreurs idiotes parce que oui oui je prends le
des choses comme ça, alors nous sommes là pour les vacances
l'exception ne signifie pas nécessairement
mais nous sommes voués à perdre
toujours de toute façon parce que j'en ressens
fois donc aujourd'hui je n'ai pas tellement aujourd'hui un
baise-nous avec qui nous sommes, nous devons
essaie toujours de gagner de toute façon
ok parce que c'est parfois ce que nous ferions
tant de choses aujourd'hui tant de choses aujourd'hui tant de choses aujourd'hui
Qu'est-ce
voici l'endroit et le terrain où presque
Il y a 14 ans, cela a commencé et a lancé le
histoire d'Excel si les garçons qui ont
formé l'équipe avec nous
ils passaient leurs après-midi sur ce terrain et
les semelles étaient littéralement usées
des chaussures parce que c'étaient des garçons
certainement différents les uns des autres avec
des intérêts différents mais ils étaient tous unis
d'une seule passion qui était celle de
le football devait sortir de là
campetto devait être une vraie équipe
membre de la fédération italienne des jeux de hasard
football et créer leur propre championnat
le désir était de sortir de là
lancer et rivaliser avec les équipes
tu mérites
nous sommes une association qui travaille dans le
sociale
nous sommes nés avec les deux domaines qui nous ont
puis identifié dans les années qui sont
indiquer la zone des dépendances ok mais
nous nous en sommes également occupés dès le début
enfants ayant des problèmes familiaux
domaine féminin dans lequel nous intervenons ensuite
J'explique le meilleur pour soutenir les femmes et
hommes victimes de traite et d'exploitation
de la prostitution parfaitement et nous
Il y a 14 ans, nous avons opté pour celui-ci
association que nous voulions essayer
utiliser le sport comme un outil
éducatif et nous avons décidé de l'essayer
couler une équipe de football
nous avons dit si d'un côté il y avait
sélection exclusion nous raisonnons
au lieu de cela, bienvenue sur l'inclusion e
égalité
on s'en fiche si tu joues
bon au football
J'aimerais comprendre si vous avez un
au lieu d'un grand désir de mesurer l'anti
avec tes limites
toucan détenteur du même statut
ça veut dire que tout le monde devant nous dit alla
l'équipe devant le ballon est égale et
sentiment qu'ils auront le même droit à
jouer les mêmes minutes dans le parcours
de l'année comme leurs compagnons et les
tournons-nous, essayons d'aller dans l'autre sens
comme toutes les équipes lors de leur premier match
il y avait une certaine émotion et nous aussi
nous sommes arrivés là-bas un peu mal préparés
nous savions déjà ce qui nous attendait
au bureau de l'arbitre pour livrer
les listes nous avions vraiment des ennuis
pour comprendre si tout était en ordre alors
échauffement sur le terrain avec moi
les joueurs qui ont bougé, regardez si
il y avait des bouteilles d'eau s'il y avait des ballons
pour le réseau
et nous voilà enfin prêts à commencer
nous sommes prêts à entrer sur le terrain et
l'arbitre nous dit que les gars ici manquent le
lignes
maintenant appelons le dit du champ
qu'avec le spargessero trace les lignes
rapide et le plus tordu jamais vu
dans l'histoire
quand on a les quatre lignes sur les côtés
mais on se rend compte qu'il manque celui des
milieu de terrain et nous demande ensuite de
nous devons tous lui donner un coup de main
la main comme ça et fais en créer une grosse
boussole humaine dessinant le cercle
Giotto avait quelque chose là aussi
dire et c'était pour que nous ayons pour le
est entré pour la première fois dans l'histoire du football et
même les lignes du terrain de football
central
puis plaignez-vous d'abord des serviettes
le mouvement fait le tout avec le
maillot de barbier en sueur mais on estime que
sont seulement ces champs jusqu'à comment
passé je n'avais pas pris et sinon
J'ai eu le ticket, je ne sais pas comment
nous avons réussi à passer et maintenant non
laisse-moi déconcentrer sur ce que nous avons commencé
mauvais jour
les gars mais je dois toujours penser à tout moi-même
Je ne pouvais pas prendre de cosmétiques privés
carte mère déjà faite puis une alliance
due conti 3 rose 4 mirko 5 alfano 6
favaretto 7 francesco 8 k 9 ivan 10
tu as 11 membres plus 12 robbie 13 ans
14 max 15 autocollants cara 16 dessus je ne veux pas
les gens protestaient aussi sur le terrain
nous savons clairement que vous avez raison
tais-toi si tu commets la faute habituelle
le discours civil s'excuse
à l'adversaire
ça ne veut pas dire que nous sommes venus
ici pour complexe mais faisons-le
respecte, personne ne sèche
les gars, vous essayez de prendre le miroir
de la porte, nous n'essayons pas de les faire
enfilé, tu sais, avec la balle autour, pas
nous sommes capables
si nous pouvons le mettre là, ça vient 2
puis que le gardien bouge
une semaine avant et met la main dessus
ok, voyons une sucette sèche
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce sera un match
très dur
nous avons cependant quelques choses à nous
service
1 nous n'avons pas besoin de gagner mais
nous y allons pour tout donner pour
ce que nous devrions tous faire quand nous sortons
pouvoir se dire qu'on a donné le meilleur de nous-mêmes
rappelons-nous également le fair-play qui
celui des nôtres est notre ticket
de la visite
bravo on dirait un sommet de la mode 8 chez les hommes
quand le ballon arrive, nous devons
manger des coups de pied de coin réguliers
marquer avant que le ballon ne parte
quand le ballon quitte les gars de l'extérieur
Je suis sorti du banc mais c'est du battage ensuite
Je vois ça dans la bouche après
tu peux faire ce que tu veux mais avant
match, vous ne fumez pas tous les deux sur le terrain si
nous suivons l'armée brancaleone comme si
nous avons dû décider que je ne vois pas de feu
dans les yeux déterminés des vilains garçons
dommage, ce n'est pas si crava en compétition
post, entrons à l'intérieur, ils ont décidé de le faire
voyez qui nous sommes
nous faisons des erreurs stupides et fondamentales
le premier quart d'heure, il semblait que le
la défense n'avait jamais joué ensemble
ils ont quelque chose de plus, ils savent qu'ils gagnent
ou le pardon, ils savent que le sourire est toujours là
qu'est-ce qui manque à tant de gens et peu
ils peuvent aussi enseigner à accepter le
vaincre avec le sourire n'est pas facile pour eux
heureux de gagner contre Excelsior, je devais le faire
être plutôt une chose facile en un
un jeu d'équipe à la demi-heure oui
réalise que nous sommes toujours 0-0
la tension monte mais voilà que dans un
ballon instantané dans la surface de réparation
nous sommes désespérés, ils sont tous heureux
sur place, le jour est
le champ plein de trous est vraiment douloureux
de flaques d'eau notre gardien devine
le coin droit du football est cependant là
la balle est trop rapide, elle semble entrer dans
porte non, la flaque d'eau ralentit ça
à tel point que cela permet à notre gardien de
touchez-le du bout des doigts et le
le ballon part en corner, réjouis-toi
toute l'équipe qu'il avait sur tous
portier
très content de ce truc en attendant
des adversaires plus intelligents que nous frappent
le corner 1 avec un coup sûr
alors que le gardien est toujours hors du but
tirer et marquer
non, personne parmi nous ne le prend
exactement sur la jambe, c'est encore une fois
sur 0 à 0 qu'est-ce que tu fais ici pitbull
course tu es l'attaquant désolé je l'étais
je suis venu complimenter pourquoi
vraiment un défilé comme celui-ci, je n'en ai jamais eu
voir
toujours sur 0 à 0 à vrai dire
mais ce match s'est terminé 4-1 pour eux
Bonjour les gars
j'ai approché les classes d'utilisation des orcs
un tel cas un dimanche au bar samhain
Je prenais un café et je parlais à Pedro
Stefano coach, je ne savais même pas
s'entraîner dans l'équipe de football e
on lui a demandé ce que tu faisais
nous avons perdu l'autre lors du dernier match
esprit à 0 20 à 0 mais quelle équipe Lénine o
et je riais aussi, je n'ai pas payé, ce n'est pas le cas
il est possible que j'aie dit que je jouais au football
pour l'âme, 20 buts ont pris un match
maintenant j'ai commencé à m'expliquer
quel était l'excès auquel j'ai approché
j'ai aussi opté au départ pour
jouer une fois joué dans le but et j'ai
j'ai commencé à m'entraîner, toutes les photos
alors pour d'autres raisons je n'ai pas pu
jouer
le groupe j'ai aimé les garçons je
Ils ont aussi aimé le projet
je suis resté en ligne maintenant c'est le cinquième
année que je collabore avec la démesure alors
le résultat, patience ou pas
nous cherchons le résultat n'est pas un
la croissance est un chemin de vie qui
des appels pour faire de ces gars quelqu'un
avec quelques problèmes et nous lui donnons le
chance pour ces enfants de
confronter d'autres possibilités que je
les équipes nées n'avaient pas de pourquoi
Malheureusement, le monde va bien maintenant
même pas bon du beau du laid nous
ça ne nous intéresse pas, tu viens avec nous
rejoignez le groupe si vous vous sentez à l'aise
parce que nous sommes une grande famille
reste à faire quoi, puis à le faire
nous vous apprenons à respecter
de l'adversaire et de l'arbitre, des choses qui
moi dans ma jeunesse quand je jouais au che
Je jouais pour gagner, certainement pas pour nous, c'était un
po peut-être même un peu grave même si c'était le cas
un peu trop exagéré et je suis
soudainement trouvé de l'autre côté à la place
et prêcher le calme et le respect des choses qui
peut-être que je n'étais pas le premier à penser à lui
la fois où j'ai appris ça et donc pour moi
cette chose et changer les gens maintenant
c'est moi qui dois dire que les gars, c'est fini
respect sur le terrain, vous pouvez le
l'équité et la loyauté envers nos
adversaire surtout perdu à vie
Ouah
tu es la Juventus de six races laides
interviewé 6
Je voulais partager le double mais avec toi
il semble que ce soit le cas principal et le même
paroisse
ce n'est pas facile aussi parce qu'avoir joué
même un certain niveau quand j'étais
jeune, lisse cette mentalité tu dois
gagner, tu dois bien faire et quand je le suis
la proposition a été faite d'entraîner et
l'excelsior je venais d'une année où j'étais
marre et fatigué et j'en ai dit assez
Je voulais rester un an pour pouvoir y aller
autour de ce vélo
si je suis mon partenaire et que je vais chez mes parents
les proches sont plutôt sous l'insistance de
maximum j'ai cédé car connaissant le
Je projette la situation des garçons
ce serait triste de ne plus les revoir
jouer ou lire les partitions sur
le journal a ensuite déchiré la promesse
que j'aurais fait l'aller-retour et au bout de deux
des semaines je lui ai dit vava massimo
allez-y doucement si vous avez besoin de trouver un
autre coach parce que j'arrête tout
l'année jusqu'à la fin je reste et c'est
ce n'est plus ma sixième saison
a accouché bien appliqué je vous le dis
tous les capots Robbie Bordon de Carlo
adresses doublure au hamas pas si
marchetti mais des essaims en ligne, je ne vais pas le faire
pise perdant rome
et puis je peux di roma les combos qui
suit
de très beaux métiers à tisser historiques qui le font toujours
étudier il s'avère
et c'est un truc qui t'appelle en premier
j'ai entendu un maximum découvert et couvert et
ils ont dit que tu devais te présenter
Samedi matin de 9 à 9 heures
Piazza va à la collection de trucs de Walter La
jouer avec les trucs pour jouer là-bas
doivent également garder leur équipe de
travaille quand tu es heureux, il y en a beaucoup moins
à bientôt, David Emmi, quand est-ce que
le tournoi toute la matinée se joue déjà de
Martin le matin ouais ok je ne voulais pas
attends attention, c'était il y a au moins
sur beaucoup
comment ça s'appelle pendant la journée
monde de la santé mentale lui-même
et il y a tellement d'associations de qui tu es
un chien de nombreuses associations vous en faites une
grosse soirée
une grande fête avec de la musique alors
ils te nourrissent, tu manges, c'est sympa
interdiction oui et puis aujourd'hui comment ça s'est passé aujourd'hui c'est
s'est bien passé, qu'est-ce qui est cuit et aujourd'hui a
cuit vaut les crevettes et le deuxième plat
poisson pescara et 96 bacalà alla vicentina
et fan de polenta est magnifique suit au moins
donc les dents des heureux grands-parents sont parfaites
puis il a dû se rendre à la grotte
a dit un caffettino, écoute-nous, c'est une annonce
Antonio, vas-y, si le
saute sur le fait qu'il m'a appelé en premier
oui, c'était un peu déprimé, un jeu un peu triste
parce qu'il m'a dit que c'était dans quelques jours
que je ne te vois pas, cela ne vaut pas sa part
fais un saut tranquille et écoute le
qu'est-ce qui a fait Téhéran
as-tu vu dans le nouveau depuis ce jour oui
tout ça par exemple
qui est-ce drôle
Merci
tout ce que le seigneur fait à ces quelques-uns
Robbie est notre gardien de but, un gardien de but
mythique qui ne ferait pas de mal
Moscou est ce qui a toujours été le
quatrième gardien de chaque équipe
pourtant dans un jeu où tout
ça semblait calme à un moment donné
Robbie sort des poteaux va vers le terrain
il l'a avec l'arbitre monte à
près de la moitié du terrain
il crie, l'insulte on comprend pas non plus
parce que notre coach qui fait oui
se lève du banc et part à leur recherche
calme-le doucement l'arbitre le ramène
il dit ou tu l'arrêtes et tu le jettes dehors
ne mets pas de rouge non pour le reste du
correspondre
permet à notre coach de se tenir debout
au lieu de sur le banc derrière le
porte, dis-lui Robbie en tant que maman statue
très bien et à la maison tout va bien à cause des ronces
ne t'inquiète pas, parlons d'autre chose
tu le feras dimanche, c'est comme ça
nous avons réussi à arriver l'esprit tranquille
jusqu'à la fin du jeu et le
adversaires adversaires de cette époque
ils n'ont plus jamais tiré au but
cela permet également d'accéder à
devenir quelque chose d'extraordinaire
date Martel cent et voir si le
d'autres vous êtes des romans que vous, peut-être que vous l'êtes
un peu plus fort et moralement tu sais
ce qu'il doit essayer de motiver
aussi l'équipe 13 quand vous bannière
comme un enfant avec une certaine discipline avec
une certaine habitude de compétition
en compétition tu trouves ça tout à fait normal
une certaine agressivité qu'on ne peut pas ici
exprimer pourquoi pourquoi faire avec
70 à 80 pour cent des personnes qui ne le font pas
ils ont grandi avec cette discipline et
ils ne savent pas comprendre pourquoi
voici des gars qui ne le sont pas
a grandi avec cet état d'esprit et si
s'ils se sentent s'ils se sentent attaqués
ils pensent que vous attaquez le
la personne, par contre, comprend que
les coûts et attaquer le jeu que nous voyons
dimanche, comme tu as dit non, je veux dire
cava je ne l'ai pas avec k je le suis parce que
J'étais loin, j'ai vu la vue du jeu
différence avec lui même si ce n'est pas le sien
ce poste est une aide que j'ai voulu apporter à
il risque de voir une différence de ton
avec lequel les choses sont dites, cependant, est
Je suis arrivé il y a deux semaines, c'est à
les portes de la maison comme une hyène, j'en vois une
qui perd le ballon et y reste ensuite
alors j'ai envie de crier, tu comprends
alors ce discours presque
mais à tout moment nous pouvons
reprendre dans le cou celui d'une équipe
ce qui est bien car il y a la démocratie
Je dois dire alors si je veux un problème, oui
propager la polémique devant tout le monde
pouvons parler face à face, nous sommes
toujours disponible est une chose
ce qui est beau à mon avis c'est que ça va partir de
nous proposons à la fin de chaque partie
je vais toujours dans tous les quartiers
au centre du terrain et loin d'un autre
salut à l'équipe
la plus belle chose à mon avis
ce que nous pourrions faire, c'est qu'on aille vers la sortie
nous faisons le couloir de 22 rangées de
joueurs on les donne à 5
bons compliments oui bonjour bonjour
félicitations tu as fait une bonne chose
de ce genre tu peux faire pour moi alors
Je ne connais pas les autres tu m'adaptes ça me trouve
difficile déjà de voyager la main je dis
au revoir bon garçon je me suis retrouvé
difficile de faire l'autre déjà dans le même
et pourquoi pas parce que quand je serai pour moi o
comment se baisser dans une salle de maladie passive
fortifié, tu dois baisser ta proue
embrassez-vous à fond, dites bonjour au milieu
sur le terrain
quels changements je parle seulement quand nous gagnons
au
un
Oui Non
D'habitude, il n'y en a qu'un, ok
je me demande si quelqu'un nous suit en fait le
rôle de conducteur, vous ne l'avez pas fait
le même schéma, c'est la même assez grande entreprise
Rien
mène à Bolsena
on va faire la blague, dit oui
Les [ __ ] du passé ont touché toute la gale
super sur penalty, il a pensé que c'était bien
et resserré, le premier était match
situation doutes perplexité mort
tout le monde joue tout le monde vient tout le monde vient
jour aussi fabio un garçon avec beaucoup
J'ai tellement de capacités mais je ne l'ai jamais fait
a foulé un terrain de football ne sait pas
même pas les règles du terrain de football e
puis dans le match plutôt agité
maintenant nos camarades disent fabio tu
tu n'as qu'une seule tâche pour marquer le chiffre 11
tu fais tout ce que fait le numéro 11
je l'ai collé, va où il est, tu ne le fais pas
ne le laisse jamais partir un instant et c'est ce qu'il fait
Fabio ne le laisse jamais partir
ferme toujours bien jusqu'à ce qu'un
certain moment du match, l'entraîneur
de l'équipe adverse remplace le
numéro 11 le numéro 11 quitte le terrain et un
à un moment donné on se rend compte que fabio lo
il a suivi jusqu'au vestiaire
nous avons dû le rappeler pour le faire
retour sur le terrain
c'est vrai tu as vu la carrière regarder avec le
veste de cuir
on dirait une Marseillaise mais pourrie
rester dans une cagoule pour voyager
nous y sommes blason sans bonne nouvelle
nous gagnons 1 0 après la première mi-temps
à trois cous sarko italease arc i
habituel
tout le monde est parti
à partir des données, nous avons progressivement une voie
Non
neuvième
Oui Non
amène le grill à des amis
Non
le défi
cours
Assez
Je pense que de Coubertin devrait te faire
un vieux monument également en châtaignier
des doutes mais Canelli fait là où il connaît les ennuis
Je sais parce que tu soulignes tous les miens
ignorance graphique merci parce que oui
il dit non, l'important c'est de participer
de coubertin tu ne penseras pas son homme
puis je l'ai toujours eu sans le savoir
qui sait qui devrait prendre un moment
parce que je pense que tu es la seule entreprise
qui joue pour Trevi tu veux perdre
vite au nôtre on essaie qui ne l'est pas
le but du projet, nous n'essayons pas
alors ça commence toujours à 0 0
enlève ma curiosité et au revoir
discipline rigoureuse sauf cataclysme
Dimanche devrait être le dixième
notre Milan l'étoile d'argent qui
maintenant je chante dans la tasse ou quelque chose comme ça
mais le but est qui nous sommes
vas-y et puis c'est tout
ta coupe des champions pourquoi pas toi
tu te vantes de la première place mais
au moins des gants, c'est une chose qui me fait plaisir
beaucoup celui-là et du reste parce que c'est
juste dans la rangée la finalité qui
va jusqu'à l'achèvement des nouveaux réseaux
a un tout d'abord merci car sur le
Journal du dimanche si tu écris à 10 heures du matin
1 et non 12 contre 1 car donner perd là-bas
Je tiens à vous dire
juste un artiste photographe qui donne
cette année, j'ai décidé de l'essayer
réaliser son propre rêve qui est de
être un artiste photographe à plein temps e
pour essayer de vivre de mon art
le photographe depuis que j'ai 15 ans et
donc pour moi d'essayer de vivre de ça
c'est vraiment la réalisation d'un rêve
comme peut-être aussi pour beaucoup de gars qui
ils jouent en celsio pouvoir jouer en
une véritable équipe de troisième ordre e
alors réalise ton rêve
il fait beau c'est beau juste parce que là
ce sont beaucoup de personnes différentes
il y a des enfants qui parlent italien
différents les uns des autres comme personnage supplémentaire
nous avons tous les garçons, les garçons
les étrangers venus s'intégrer
en combat d'équipe
peut-être qu'en Italie il y en a un peu moins
culture de l'immigration parce qu'on
la chose la plus récente que nous, les Italiens, ayons jamais été
j'avais l'habitude d'aller à l'étranger pendant un moment
les années sont les autres qui viennent à nous
c'est la nouveauté
mais je pense que seuls les exemples comme
ex Chelsea ou ils peuvent changer pour le leur
petit pour l'entreprise, je pense que l'ancien
il faut vraiment garder à l'esprit comment
un bel exemple d'intégration
sociale
comment les aliments italiens
J'ai entré le short pass 20 pour moi il y a
mal
ils savent
ici à Buggiano Sicile Spa Rose Life par
le meilleur endroit pour que nous puissions faire les choses au bon endroit
lochis milano ou génois hoskins les fans
dans les paniers il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ils ont des caractères de sensibilité qui sont
très labile très particulier alors
ce n'est pas facile de vivre ensemble, ce n'est pas toujours
facile de vivre ensemble
il y a eu des disputes
des conflits il y a eu des situations
difficile et donc nous tous chacun
nous entraîner à chaque match que nous devons
apprendre à gérer nos limites pour
ne tombez pas dans la discussion dans le
querelle et donc c'est un laboratoire
social très important parce que le
les gens pensent que nous nous amusons
perdre on s'amuse à rire un peu
comme si nous étions un peu stupides
léger mais en réalité il y a du travail
important derrière pourquoi
pouvoir conserver la sérénité et
la joie du groupe
tu dois apprendre beaucoup de choses
les gens qui sont proches de nous qu'en dites-vous
si vous souhaitez venir vous entraîner de temps en temps
les femmes boivent de bons vins avec lui là-bas
Je pense que rester en forme est maintenant nécessaire
arrêté, ce n'est pas le smash que tu as arrêté qui est un
famille
la seule équipe a joué hier
j'ai joué à Naples un album dans l'album e
puis Bausano et ensuite Excelsior
voici la fesse en dernier dans le sens
lekesiz similaire qu'as-tu fait c'est
vérifié que vous avez signé et tout au long du
vie
il est recommandé de donner un pourboire à sa médaille d'église
même maman qui est bonne à tout prix
ce qui est beau car la coupe est rare
ma discipline à 10 000 toriques et
comme elles sont belles toutes les 4, belle mère
Mirabelle, souviens-toi qu'il en est ainsi, même si les actionneurs
la deuxième fois mais pour appeler un
commun toi le jaguar notre programme
et pas les deuxièmes meilleures répliques du
il marque dans tout le Tyrol du Sud et à Téhéran
cette pompe
j'ai fait voler un V8 avec un gang
et le monoxyde motivé tache le sexe
vrai tout le col du jeu de crédit très connu
papa à 62 ans
mais s'il pleut avec Daniele, c'est plus calme
Daniele a fait faillite mais en dessous c'est quoi
pour moi la première nuit où tu es arrivé
dans le camp il ne me connaissait pas mais avec le monde
du viseur a dit à peu près si je me souviens bien
que nous étions, nous faisons des séances d'entraînement et
lapo a vu 33 bustes derrière le
la porte est en deux versements, victime il ou lui
ils me ressemblent à une veste avec tout le
les étalons tu connais
oui mais ils avaient déjà eu un gilet
avec des clous et de la chaîne
quelque chose alors Walter me fait max
essaie d'entrer à l'intérieur 12
soyons chanceux en euros
nous voyons que beaucoup ont lentement lentement
il y en avait aussi avant le match
aimait déjà faire la fête avant son arrivée
le lot plutôt modifié peut-être avec
quelques verres de trop pendant la
jeu alors ça t'arrive
réaliser que pendant que tout le monde joue, on est
là, ça dit que je m'ennuie maintenant toi
tu ne me passe plus le ballon et ça arrive
bronzer tranquillement
au milieu du terrain en effet il décolle le
maillot de football et toujours sous le
chemise de pyjama où mais sur 15 à 0
essayez des mouvements à quoi ça sert n'essayez pas
Perfectionnez-vous, utilisez-le comme entraînement.
tu te rends parfait et ensuite sur les choses que tu
ils viennent automatiquement comme on l'a dit
fille, un de mes amis a dit que tu devais le faire
essayer essayer
quand il retourne chez son partenaire, il part
cet autre
J'ai toujours joué à des niveaux élevés
Je tiens vraiment à ce sport
et puis pour moi, c'est me mettre dedans
jeu et prouver qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
de 11 personnes qui savent jouer au football
mais ils font la différence, ils font la différence
différence les câlins des gens
des câlins même de la part de ceux qui ne le font pas
ils jouent dans les gens qu'ils représentent
les bancs vous regardent les gens qui
ils ont des problèmes physiques qu'avec les dieux
les petits gestes vous en donnent plus d'un
but de gagner un jeu et pour nous et
pour moi c'est une victoire et ça m'a
j'ai beaucoup appris
dans la vie, respecte le prochain de chacun
c'est facile d'aller sur le terrain avec 11
joueurs de football et gagnez le match
mais il faut du courage, il faut
Vraiment
la patience demande vraiment de la force
personnage pour entraîner 11 encore plus que
onze parce que nous sommes une équipe
très grand avec tant de têtes différentes
là où ils ne savent pas jouer, va sur le terrain e
faire un résultat
un point dimanche pour nous c'est le match
le plus important de l'année
nous nous souvenons, nous commémorons et nous quittons
disons aussi célébrons le nôtre
camarade qui n'est rien de plus que Daniele
Daniele était un gars qui nous avait
laissé un grand écart est aussi un
excellent enseignement parce que c'était un
garçon très malade mais avec nous celui-là
la maladie comme par magie
laissez-le hors du terrain à chaque fois
à tel point que beaucoup d'entre nous, moi y compris, le font
ils ont vraiment réalisé la gravité
de sa maladie
seulement quand il était déjà mort, pense
Je le dis seulement pour les nouveaux qu'il a
nous sommes partis il y a quatre ans alors que nous
nous jouions à un jeu
la nouvelle est arrivée pendant que nous
nous avons joué même si nous l'avons
a décidé de ne pas le dire pendant le match
probablement l'énergie ou quelque chose comme ça était là
dans les airs parce que dans ce match là
nous avons eu trois cartons rouges 3 4
des remontrances bref, nous le sommes vraiment
il y a vraiment eu beaucoup de tension
j'aime croire qu'il y a même
lui aussi sur le terrain avec nous c'est
plus nous entrons dans le domaine, plus nous le faisons
nous offrons ce cadeau à tous
maximum alors pars avec la fête pour elle
et on s'amuse
son honneur
la tête
Fabio a raison de le lui donner quand il l'a
tourné
tous
coupe sur 4 à partir de
Non
tome
je trouve
Oui Non
Non
à Fabio ci-dessous
les garçons de coqs
but
né
une personne m'a dit une phrase
au début de l'expérience Excel si
il est toujours resté ici et pour moi c'était
comme une balise sur laquelle guider l'itinéraire e
elle a dit que personne, même le plus
grand champion, ce n'est même plus le champion
payé au monde pourra faire une belle
match de ce jour donné si vous participez
sur le terrain pendant un moment ne pourra pas
je sens cette herbe
cette odeur de sable qu'il ressentait
enfant quand il allait jouer pendant des heures
avec ses amis sur le terrain pour briser le
genoux ou pour épuiser les écoles de
semelles de chaussures uniquement pour les purs
amusant
et ce qui reste de la fleur
j'en dis plus
ici, ils viennent aux mains et aux mains
images
tous ensemble entre les deux
bien